bonjour now we're here in the most
liberal country in Europe I believe
Spain asking people about what they
think of lgbts since they're taking over
right now
cuantos genderos and Stan it's LGBT
month right now so we're just out here
trying to figure out how many genders
are there I think ten there's ten
there's ten genders I believe so by now
yeah I mean I heard there was 12
recently really yeah wow that's
surprising um well Everybody's Free to
choose what they want and what they like
if they're happy with their choices I
respect that I recently just came out as
a dinosaur really oh that's okay I'm a
conservative person I don't care I
sexually reproduce with a reptilian
beings
that's crazy that's great that's kind of
transphobic yeah
yeah we're trying to figure out how many
genders are there how many genders yeah
uh a lot like how many do you know I
don't know I'm up to I'm up to 24. 24.
yeah are there more yeah I think so
there are a lot but I don't know can you
name any of them
just trying to figure it all out you
know it's a lot of new stuff it's pride
month so it's important to be accepting
what do you think of kids under the age
of 10 transitioning to the other gender
through like they're not in the good
body I think they need to do that yeah I
agree because like you know when I was
eight I believed in in Santa Claus and
stuff and I also believed I was an NHL
player but you know I think that um if I
knew I was a woman I feel like I should
have acted on that earlier yes I think
so too I agree how do I know I'm not a
woman I don't know what do I look like
uh like a man
I'm done
how many genders genders only two no
only two yes male and female what do you
think about them extending pride month
until the end of summer yeah but yeah
it's so fine it's fine yeah and then all
right what do you think about kids
transitioning genders at a young age
yeah it's a normal process right now in
this generation is it good you okay with
it and normal yeah so like eight year
olds
cutting off their wiener yeah good yeah
how many genders um three I guess three
I don't know more what are the three
genders
I don't know
France trans yeah can a man be a woman
of course what what is a woman woman but
you mean
what do you mean biologically gender is
not like you can say just
um gender social gender or then we may
think about the social gender or the
biological gender you can identify as a
woman does that make me a woman they
wave seeds for me you are a man but it's
true I identify as a woman if you
identify as a woman you can say you're a
woman but biologically you're a mom so
you're a doctor yeah what so if someone
comes in that's a biological woman but
says they're a man you treat them as a
woman or a man
if you want
um is he or she whatever they identify
as so can a woman get testicular cancer
yeah no yes what they said but they said
there man yeah but gender is not like
you don't have to say things like guys
black or white is uh
a scale of grade scale of rain what do
you think of the new bill in the U.S for
three-year-olds to start transitioning
in three years old I don't agree with
that because at least in Spain there are
people who are regretting for changing
their gender so what what age do you
think people should be able to I think
more than 18. at least at least they
were based on the age thing that's a
doctor though that's a doctor saying
that stuff how are the doctors not more
based from girls
um
my man
how many genders are there
two
yeah whoa whoa whoa that's transphobic
no books and gender oh sex and gender
are different they taught us that in
English class too English class physics
class history class I was taught in all
of them how gender and sex are now
different lately Society has been
changing the meaning of words we've
known as basic truth since the start of
the English language gender and sex now
aren't the same thing GDP falling for
two quarters isn't a recession we're not
in recession racism isn't prejudiced
against another race it's oppression
from an oppressing race a woman is
someone who calls themselves a woman and
trans people are undergoing a genocide
in states where anti-trans legislation
has gone through people are going to die
people have already died the elites are
very smart about how they push this
agenda they push slowly over time eating
away is what you see as a basic reality
do you remember when it was just LGB
when feminism and racism were literally
just about equality when forced vaccines
were seen as evil you cannot force
someone to take a vaccine we cannot
require someone to be vaccinated don't
forget their agenda stay conscious
constantly and remember which direction
their trying to push you into what do
you identify as are you a woman
right yes
I don't want to assume
do you not have this in France no no so
how many how many genders are there one
just one just one I know who do you
reproduce with what do you think of
six-year-olds transitioning to the other
gender is good it's good yes why is it
good but it's free yeah to do what they
want it's better for them okay can a man
become a woman yes it's good I'm a woman
okay I don't care it's good for you okay
that's very nice meeting you girl should
transgender women be able to play in
women's sports
be able to play in women's sports I
identify as a woman yes
yes a boxing yeah but it's not a woman's
parties oh there's women's boxing do you
think LeBron James should be able to
play in the women's NBA yeah no but they
couldn't compete between each other you
have different strengths they men have
more testosterone than women oh so they
shouldn't be they shouldn't be able to
not together like because women can get
harm yeah it's something physical
biological but I identify as a woman I
identify as a woman I identify so I I'm
sorry so I can't play no you can play
but not compete because they somehow
some people maybe women can get harm I
don't understand should transgender
women be allowed to play in women's
sports yeah yeah so like you know LeBron
James yes should he be able to play in
The Women's National Basketball League
yeah
yeah yes I don't know you think that's
fair yes what do you play any sports
Denise tennis do you think it'd be fair
to have men biological men competing
against you yes why not do you think men
are stronger than women no physically no
no where are you guys from Spain Spain
yeah that makes sense how'd the
interviews go a lot of Libs in Spain
told you what do you think we should go
for some better better interviews we got
to leave Europe Society let's go to the
motherland
[Music]
for money
talk to me about it
[Music]
we came to Morocco to find out how many
genders are there
two two yeah female and male what what
is a female what's a woman she's very
different from a male like
like the
the aspect she's built she's built
friendly she's uh emotionally attached
she's emotionally attached that's that's
done okay maybe I'm a woman
thinks more emotionally than uh you know
than the man yeah
biologically there's only two yeah
scientifically biology I thought there
was like 40. I know biologically
speaking there's two genders there's
males and females what is a woman
what is a woman a woman is everything
it's everything yeah so like what's the
difference between a woman and a man
like can I become a woman I don't think
so you can't no I can't you can't why so
what is a woman a woman can can give
birth to Children you can't what do you
think about he's more affectionate than
men yes agree she can do everything but
men can't do everything I guess that
women are much more better than men and
you're a school teacher right yeah wow
that's amazing and um what do you think
about in the USA teaching that men can
be women and there's a million different
genders do you think that's bad for
children I guess so do you guys
celebrate pride month in Morocco pride
month what is it you don't even know
what this is no the rainbow Flags
everywhere oh no no none of that here I
don't
I personally
we came all the way here from the USA to
find out how many genders are there uh
here two two for me too there's only two
here yes because normally well basically
there's a hundred in the USA I know it's
a little bit uh I don't know but uh
what what do you think about not normal
what do you think about the transgender
movement I'm not against that but I'm
against the the fact they that they
impose that to other people live your
life do your thing and leave others
alone don't go to schools to say to
Children I'm a drag queen I'm
transgender you can choose babies can
choose let them be kids let them be kids
what do you do you think happy have fun
I don't know do you think Trend kids can
be transgender no it's against nature
are you Muslim yes I'm a Muslim I fast I
do Ramadan everything awesome I pray too
real quick it's been nearly a year since
we started my YouTube channel absolutely
unreal we're almost half a million Subs
as you guys know I haven't done any
brand deals at all on this channel I
only want to promote stuff that I fully
endorse and use or product that I own so
I can ensure top tier quality you guys
have been asking for a lot more of my
marketing and business secrets so I
finally decided to launch a total
totally free newsletter where I'll be
showing all these exact cheat codes that
I use to generate seven figures before
ever starting YouTube and then those
same cheat codes that I converted into
the sunny fast brand that you now all
know that have gotten me over a billion
views this year the first email is a
full free training gonna absolutely blow
your mind but the downside is I'm only
letting 500 people get access to this
from there it's going to be tough to get
in so I'm leaving the link at the top of
the description good luck wow
it's pretty we came all the way to
Morocco from the USA to find out how
many from USA from USA
nice to meet you too how many genders
are there I don't understand you do you
speak Arabic yeah I speak English
that's it that's it in the USA there's
like 200 genders now they keep inventing
them
no
[Laughter]
can I be a woman no you can't why can't
I be a woman
for energy because a woman can do a lot
of things
like working in the home and working out
home would you girls like to stay home
no you want to work and raise the baby
yeah yeah
what if the man makes a lot of Guapo
then you stay home no no you're thinking
about it no no why why do you want to
work too because we want to
so what do you guys think about like
transgenders it's her life
yeah it's Haram we know but you're still
nice to them yes that's the thing you
like yeah you're still gonna be nice
agreed respect our religion 100 what do
you think about them showing
transgenders and stuff to kids no no so
if you want to do it do it in your own
time and don't show the kids yeah
vendors are there that's it baby foreign
sugar daddy sugar daddy that's the other
gender okay I'm sugar I'm sugar daddy no
no no yes no no they're not trying to
impose their views onto other people
they're like when you ask them what do
they think about transgenders like okay
that's fine you do your own thing but
just respect my religion and I respect
you if you want to go cut your nuts off
go cut your nuts off but you don't got
to teach my kids that a boy can be a
girl so I know everyone here has been
really respectful so far it's kind of
what I've taken away from this how many
genders are there just
that's it yes no more no no could I be a
woman
what
what what's up my friend
how are you
um I'm doing good all right two genders
can I can I be a woman or no no no no no
I can't that's Haram no no never never
never
in the USA you can ah wait here in in
Morocco my uh My Relations Islam is uh
it's not uh Haram Haram yes all right
thank you brother well we came all the
way to Morocco from the USA to find out
how many genders there are genders it's
like about female and males yeah they're
like how many are there actually I think
it's 50 15 Morocco so we're about 38
million so I suppose
um for males it's about um 19 million 10
million and four females 90 million I
suppose it's funny like they don't even
understand the question here because it
sounds so ridiculous to them so now in
the USA you have people saying like well
are you talking about sex or gender well
there could be a million genders but
there's only two Sexes on here it's like
that's all programming in the US that's
all that stuff is you don't naturally
think there's more than two genders
because it's asinine and 100 years when
they dig up our bodies in the ground
they're not going to say he identified
as a wolf you're a man so here they're
just not as programmed you know they
stick to real life and that's how it is
the more you leave those first world
societies it's just more normal none of
this extra they're not they're
not even bothered with the topic so like
you can like ask him about it about it
they like they don't even know what
you're talking about because they don't
have like they don't really talk about
it like every day like for example in
the US it's like a common occurrence to
talk about yeah in school like literally
I remember being Middle School there was
a transgender kid high school they're
teaching us about that stuff it's funny
how in the US they say like oh the U.S
is the most racist place in the world
they're going to move out and it's like
we're the most like accepting yeah you
come here and that doesn't slide
they don't even want cultures mixing
here that's what I've noticed I mean if
you're in France well the people that
I'm at there they wanted to keep the
culture strictly French you know they
don't want other people coming in and
mixing everything keep the croissants
and the wine in France like you said
there accepting but I feel like there
should be limits you know what I mean
they should be accepting back to like a
certain degree because otherwise you're
gonna just start like allowing
everything and anything and that's not
good for anyone
okay we went to Spain and they didn't
really help me in finding out how many
different genders there are I talked to
medical professionals and they told me
that there can be up to 100 genders and
gender and sex aren't the same thing so
we came all the way to Morocco to find
out and I think we came to the
conclusion that there's only two what do
you think brother how many genders
only men and women that's it that's it
see look at this guy knows best right
here
all the answers of the world with him
and his camel thank you guys so much for
watching I'll see you later
[Music]